here at the opposition when we want to
relax we need to feel safe this is how
real America does yoga I take all my
style and firearm safety in SPO from my
personal hero Tommy Lehren Tommy took a
lot of flack for concealed carry yoga
pants but this is what safety looks like
guns like yoga are two of the great
white traditions people keep talking
about common sense yoga pants and I just
don't think those will work now I can be
the good guru with a gun that stops the
bad guru with a gun or negative energy
but both can be good and when I really
need to decompress I crank up the heat
for some hot yoga room for one more
Oh actually yes we lost someone last
week
[Music]